yes so finally
king of UK update
I'm gonna take back on for there for you
all right 3 very
very important update for my people
in fact before you watch this video
just share just share
just share um
things are really getting hard and getting difficult
especially for people that want to travel to UK
so the British Council has increased islet fee
that English exam that you have to write
if you want to travel to UK
especially if you are coming for care job
or you know
most of this job
even all these plumbling plumber
all those ones I advertise
before you have to write that
I like the exam IELTS
so they've increased the 200 and 507,500 Nair
used to be seventy something thousand
to eighty something thousand
to ninety something thousand
nine is about hundred and seven thousand five hundred
that's number one of dates
so just stop preparing
No. 2 that Germany and that Canada
own No. 2
UK don't come out
care health care job assistant
they don't come out
and you know the for skilled job again
and you know another skilled job named it
they are to visa
where did they give since January
healthcare job now would not be here since
you see that's why sometimes if opportunity come out
grab it immediately
since December
I have been making videos
I gave you people the criteria
I told you everything to do
up to 19 people said from this
my page through that link came to UK
no they didn't
they saturated
they don't promote them from skilled job
that is to say
what it means is that
it is only those that are senior carers and home carers
home carers now do Miss Laddie
people that go from house to house
nice to do for that skilled job visa so
um I don't know how we will receive this news
but they did not
this thing was done in 23rd February 2,023
but was updated 9th of August
just few days ago
but they have not put a date when they will stop people
so probably if you are still planning to come
you can still come
hopefully the last one
each time I update about how to travel
how to travel
people will be asking me
and only people will go school
if you come UK
what are people will not go school my brother
you know this country now
first class country
country waiting for No. 1
First World War country
for this country now 9 9
90 something percent of the citizens are literate
enough they went to school
is not like our Africa where they
do you understand
that's why they define skilled
when people will get something to offer
they believe in academics
Nigeria you can go to primary
stop at primary six
and become a millionaire or billionaire
Nigeria you can have 1,000 today
and have hundred million tomorrow
you can have hundred million today
and have 10,000 tomorrow
it cannot happen in this country
you have to follow that process
it cannot happen
listen
UK is a country where you say
you can still apply your life for the next 5 years
I know everything that will happen
there's no way money will come
I know it's only my salary
nothing else anywhere
if you didn't go to school
there is something you can do
why not find a medical person
good friend them
why not find a nurse
I've done a video
I haven't done a
I did a video where I told you people
hospitals in UK that are recently employing losses
is on my page
I mentioned the name of the hospital and told you
and there are so many of you that are losses
married do court winning get walk
you go fuller and commerce dependent
the dependent where they stop now only for student visa
use your brain now share this video